يعاني الجيش الالماني قصورا ونقصا كبيرين
في المعدات لدى الاكثر من ذلك ان اذا انها
ثلثي السلاح المدفعيه معطل ولا يعمل طبعا
وفقا لمعلومات كشافتها تايمز البريطانيه
التي تقول انما عدات القوات المسلحه
الالمانيه في حاله سيئه وذلك في حين بدات
برلين سد بعض الثغرات في قدراتها من خلال
صندوق لاعاده التسليح بقيمه 100 مليار
يورو ياتي هذا الحديث اثر ايام من تعطر
مجموعه كامله من مركبات المشات القتاليه
في اثناء التدريب خلال احدى مهام حلف حلف
شمال الاطلسي النيته ومن بين تلك الاسلحه
اكتشفت قياده الفرقه 10 مدرعه في الجيش
الالماني عن مشاكل فنيه متعدده مع مركبات
القتاليه من طراز بوما خلال اختبار اطلاق
النار والقتال ليه تدريبات الناتو الاخيره
لذلك
اوقفت الدفاع الالمانيه شرائها حاليا وكان
من المفترض ان تكون بوما العمود الفقري
لقوه المهام المشتركه التابعه للنيتو
وتقودها المانيا وهي وحده من المفترض
نشرها بسرعه لحمايه الجبهه الشرقيه
للتحالف في حال حدوث غزو مدافع الحوض سعر
ذاتيه الدفع والتيورتها برلين ومع ذلك من
بين ال 105 من الهوت سر الالمانيه فقط
ثلاثه وسبعون متوفره للجيش بحسب تقرير
حكوميه داخلي ويقال ان حواله نصف تلك
الانظمه قيد الاستخدام فيما يتم اصلاحه 18
اخرى لدى ورش صناعه الاسلحه
حتى في اوكرانيا ارسل مالا يقل عن سته من
الحاضر الالماني من اصل 14 مدفعا تم
تقديمها للجيش الاوكراني للاصلاح في
ليتوانيا وسط حاله نقص بقطع الغيار
[موسيقى]